oh you just got here our stance is that
when it comes to act yet so for example
if a woman
if for example a woman is being raped
yes I'm not gonna go and concentrate and
say you know okay who was the woman
raped by it was a Christian okay now I
will go after that Christian the issue
that I have is this yeah
is that we hate the act whoever does it
we don't give he's a Muslim we don't
give you the cushion we don't give you
the Hindu Buddhist green black you know
multicultural colors whatever it may be
you can say so my problem with Tony
Robinson is the following when it's a
Muslim doing the foot issue I found in
Cambridge yeah as a discussion with him
because he's claiming he does he's
reading a book and the book says why
Muslims kill for Islam okay now if I
writes a book about how a car works I
should know what I'm talking about
right cuz I've written a whole menu on
how a car works so when you come to me
say Ali you've written a book about how
does cars work can you tell me how does
the gearbox work and I go yeah but what
about the sky we're gonna say hold on a
second Ali I'm asking you how this is
the gearbox work
yeah but here but what about the trees
so you gonna see Ali can you answer my
question I'm gonna say but what about my
trainers you let me see Ali why are you
diverting the topic and this is exactly
what happened when I met Tommy Robinson
because he goes in channel 4 on BBC on
ITV and says this Quran here they want
to kill all the infidels and all the
pupar and I want to take all of us cup
this ok sounds interesting to your
f---ing it sounds very dramatic
yeah can you substantiate what you're
claiming you've made the statement why
we Muslims kill for Islam ok Tommy can
you bring me a single verse in the
entire history of the
[Music]
[Music]
which is a place where freedom of speech
is all yes it's not for you to dominate
it's not for people to come and
intimidate and use violence which is
happened
[Music]
okay so you made love accusations alley
in your book it says we are killed
aquifer farm use dirty alley you went
off the Tommy Robinson and her
okay good and well maybe it's anything
that I missed yet so you made these
massive accusations yeah so now I want
to answer them because the reason I'm
here it's the dialogue
well internal rubbish is said let's have
a boxing match I said me it's easy to
fall punches it's not for punches but
I'm not no matter what it's for
he's a violent man I'm not I don't know
yeah you're right did I find with did I
find when you guys with so so therefore
therefore look I I'm the aggressor so
let's just find out here number one you
claim that my book the Quran teaches me
me to kill - a non-muslim right can you
kindly bring me a symbol not two not
three not four one verse that says
Muslims for you to be a good jihadi and
to go to heaven and have your version 3
version or from them you have to
wherever you find the Kafar kill them
can you please kindly put in context
that I am supposed to be killing you you
okay good carry we we buried in some way
around there yeah so now I want to say
is this year you claimed you just gave a
quote you said in the Quran it says my
clinics wherever we find them that's
like me going to a church of stamen the
same when we fight the Germans shoot
them in the head cut everything out I'm
making a point
yeah please kind of do not just dive it
off that to Robinson yeah now if I said
Churchill said shoot the Germans in the
head what kind of violence is that
you're gonna see Ali hold on a second
come on Ali be just churchill was
talking about in a state of war because
when you go to war guys i don't know
anyone been to war hopefully not yet
when you go to all you do not throw
roses you do not throw flowers and kiss
your opponent they're enemies there to
attack you you have to defend yourself
so when the Quran talks about smiting
the next the scene of that verse
actually talks about the angels number
one number one is talking about angels
who came to help the Prophet against the
aggressors because when we go to surah
Burroughs
seven unless it's in the Quran indeed it
was those who attacked you first and it
was those who kicked you out of your
houses so if I come to your house ladx
and say you know what I don't like you
because you're white I own your house
now and I'm gonna kill your family would
you give me a kiss on the cheek okay you
cleaned I didn't call you said yeah so
now I'm just asking because the highest
form of ignorance is talking about
something I did because we've got
somebody who's written a whole book
about why we Muslims kill for Islam but
when I asked him a simple question Tommy
can you kindly show me one verse
did anybody guys who watch my video when
I went to Colonel Robinson who watch my
video we answer when I asked him the
question 12 times that's okay there's a
same ladies first so let's respect them
when I went to tell you a consent I do
now when I want to tell Robinson if I'm
an expert on how cause function it
doesn't matter at what point when I'm
drinking my tea having this you know
why haven't I answered all this question
giving the answer mine 12th time so once
again I'm gonna ask please can you show
me a verse in our it's coming into this
tense Ali Ali I'm an orphan of losing my
direction wasn't it I do not should have
called my villagers I'm telling you I
follow Islam to be better to my villages
now what you're doing is you're
diverting the truth I'm seeing where
does it teach us to kill innocent people
okay no there's no Vesco surah hi
brilliant that's actually that's
actually worse I love it everyone fixes
that how can you tell me why was reverse
toba verse 29 revealed no no those are
you different so sooner 30 was it
revealed separately or together the
Quran did not come down as surah tauba
all at once it came in different your
people your context you made the claim
eeeh you said surah 9:29 clearly says
there was a cure yes okay no it doesn't
listen no no no sorry
what's your PhD on Islamic science it's
not a PhD so then why you making claim
is that you and I'm unclear
no it doesn't came down
I know sorry sorry so for example I'm
asking you have no idea why
Oh gonna be the context fight against
those who do not believe in Allah or in
the last stage and you do not consider
localize unless you have made and you
no no no I don't like divergent that's
on a Robinson we don't my favorite fight
against those who do not believe in
Allah nor in the last stages you know
consider unlawful what Allah and his
messengers made unlawful and who do not
adopt the religion of truth is down from
them to you guys well fight against
those who do not believe in Allah or in
the last day and who do not consider
unlawful what Allah and His Messenger
have made or unlawfully finish any
finish and who do not the religion of
truth from those who were given the
scripture
I'm gonna give the context I'm going to
give context no no no no no that says
the Jews there is range of Allah this is
did you say that son of Allah and the
Christians say the Messiah is the son of
Allah that is their statement from their
mouth they imitate the same of those who
displayed before them yes may Allah
destroy them how do you do they are so
so now it was not does he say there's a
verse end by saying Allah orders you to
go attack them because of this no you're
claiming here that this is saying go and
attack Christians and Jews by default
because they believe in what they
believe
since nonsense can you please show me
here comes a sama so one two three four
five idea for by myself trying to answer
your question this verse what would do
is we'll go to will go to the beginning
yeah okay this is the declaration of
dissociation from Allah and his
messenger the to those who you had him
made a treaty what's the treaty treaty
was the treaty an agreement for what I'm
seeing
we are context yeah okay we're gonna
vote you first first 13 guys context
yeah would you not fight against eight
people
he broke their oath so there's a no
that's been broken there was a promise
is that say name you were gonna live in
harmony like I said the lone sovereign
can we leave in how many she said no
universal so and determined to expel the
messenger and they had began the attack
upon you first context good so now it's
not my community wasn't thank you know
neither he was at Pearl Harbor Japan
Japan when the America made Odin said
fight the Japanese was worthy telling
the soldiers to fight the innocent
Japanese or the Japanese are fighting
them Japanese fighting didn't have an
awesome when we're gonna vote was very
nice place
a very nice place when when when when
once again when America made order said
Japan is attacked Pearl Harbor go and
fight the Japanese did they go to even
though they did that Hiroshima Nagasaki
they attacked innocent people but the
soldiers say you know what we're gonna
go to Japan I start shooting kids and
children know they were fighting the
Japanese use the Japanese the ones who
will come over their place the
suicide bombers and driving into the
ships right now they are not talking
about innocent Japanese so when in the
Quran Allah mentions fighting the
Christians and the Jews with context
this is talking about the Battle of
Tabuk the Romans were coming 40,000
strong sure sure sure
share context okay thank you very much
madam you keep you okay you will go
another way when the chief comes out you
get people come from all corners
sir sir Sir I don't so can I speak to
you so in the Battle of Tabuk or might
even cut up a companion of the Prophet
one day one of his companions came and
knocked on the door bang bang bang bang
and he rushed down and open the door
what's going on he said has the Romans
come why did he say that because they
were so talks about the Christians and
the Jews who have been aggressive no way
in the Quran does the older Muslims to
go out right and kill I'm finished kill
you you - these young ladies oh you my
friend nowhere
so these Isis scumbags who go and run
innocent people over are my biggest
enemy you know why
okay Christians and Jews to destroy them
no because for example at the time of
the problem there was a treaty and in
the treaty it says that they go when
there is a treaty that says Allah from a
line is messenger
allow me to answer yeah the at the time
of the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him yet he lived side by side with the
Jews and the Christians and they have
the cheat sheet and in the treaty in a
way says the Christians have a right to
live in peace
they will not be forced to fight with
the Muslim mr. Muslim enemy all Romans
are coming to attack the Muslims the
Christians have no rights they have
their hominid living harmony and based
this verse